okay here's another huge influence on
you and you mention in the book the
ferris buer ferris bu's uh day off you
you uh yes that was a huge influence on
you because he broke the fourth wall
that was yeah that was mind-blowing I
mean it was so I mean what one of the
smartest moves of a of a movie script
ever I think I me sure not the first
movie but definitely of those Coming of
Age films which I was all about I just
liked all the things that he
accomplished in a day I mean it was
insane and like is he going to make it
you know all that rascally principal you
know and his sister was kind of badass
you know like there was so many
adventurous things and it only took
place in a day and then at the end like
him or just once in a while throughout
the movie too but like looking at the
camera I was like that is so cool I love
that like we're in on it like he's like
he's experiencing that reality for us
and also it's very hard to do because it
can be done badly yes and of course uh
John Hughes and Matthew to brri that
just they did it perfectly perfectly
yeah it was just like prag it was
practical it's kind of a perfect movie
it's it's totally a perfect movie I I've
watched it you know some some some of
those movies are like but um just
moments of it are kind of you know
Breakfast Club this is totally aside and
random but I was down uh
in uh Venice uh in here in California
with David hopping like a week and a
half ago and we wander into a store and
I'm chatting with the guy who runs the
store and he says uh to a woman there
who's also working there this very
attractive woman who's probably in her
early 20s more mid 20s and he says to
her I I can't remember her name but he
says like you know Celia Celia tell
Conan your story tell her your story and
she comes over kind of sheepishly
because she's being forced to and she
says um my parents are the parents on
Ferris berer I said what what do you
mean and she said the the two actors
that play the mother and the father on
Ferris berer they met on that movie and
they're my parents oh my God and then
the guy at the store is like isn't that
crazy oh and at this point I feel like I
have to buy something
um uh yeah and uh they met on that movie
and then she is their child and uh she
is drop dead gorgeous by the way God
yeah and very nice and very cool but I
just thought wait a minute are you just
are you insane that you think because
when you think of people who are playing
a couple in a movie you never think and
she said no they met on that movie and
then uh had me she's the real life bu
she is the real life berer God yeah that
a cool story she's real berer that's
crazy and does she ever just randomly
stopped in the middle of the street just
turned to a camera that's not there well
I was get hello to me yeah yeah she did
while I was talking to her yeah she
turned to a camera that wasn't there and
said I meet us a lot of celebrities at
at this store here uh you know in uh in
near Venice Beach uh Conan kind of
bottom of the of the pile but you know
what you got to pretend to be excited
and then she turned back to me oh you
were still there I was still there man
and I said that's rude and then she
turned back to a different camera and
said who knew he could hear me multicam
mulam wall she broke she broke the fifth
wall she broke so many walls the roof
collaps to do oh my God she's living in
a hyper C anyway I don't know her name
but shout out to her and and and very
lovely cool person glad know that that's
mindblowing yeah yeah I love
berer berer is great but also I love
Weird Science Weird Science was huge
like Weird Science Weird Science is so
insane so insane because I'm sorry but
the premise is the premise is crazy it's
because I remembered seeing that this is
how old I am I saw that in the theater
as an adult who could choose to purchase
or not purchase a ticket with Craig
Daniels because we were both writers and
we had you know no girlfriends big
surprise we're living out here in LA and
this movie comes out Weird Science and
we think well let's go to Westwood and
watch it to learn how to make a
girlfriend yeah exactly we both need to
make a girlfriend clearly cuz we no one
we meet wants to talk to us so we go to
this theater and these two guys just
basically I think cut out a bunch of
pictures from magazines and feed them
into a what a super computer a super
then aier then Barbie doll the the out
for and there's a Barbie doll and then I
think because they run a cable to the
roof and lightning hits it that makes
Kelly Le Brock that's true yeah they
designed her on the computer I know but
I was like the leaps people were making
with you know if you take a personal
computer and there's a lightning storm Y
and you have a bra and some dolls around
you can make Kelly Le computer were
still like fancy enough that you
couldn't pin it down for oh could it do
that yeah I know people just didn't
question it they're like that'll happen
I guess that can happen with a computer
and a lightning storm if they both Happ
at the same time very hard so you know
those kids got lucky in that movie I I
remembered that happening and being like
a 22-year-old in the theater and just
saying okay I guess I really don't
understand
computers I'm glad I'm glad that that
but myself and my writing partner we
went out that night we bought an apple
we bought seven Barbies and you're still
waiting and uh Greg was
electrocuted no le
Brock there he is electrocuted
lackless the police the firefighters
showed up and all they said when they
saw us we were both smoldering was
trying to make a Le huh a lot of that
lately we got two more nerds on
barington trying to make a Leck you two
stop lecking around get out of here
enough Le Bren you
idiots the power surges going in these
different nerd areas of town then some
then some shadow creature emerges in the
background um I mean yeah that show was
I mean also it had Mad Max Vibes in it
it had like I mean it had every it was
so crazy the guy from Mad Max yeah the
guy from Mad Max was in it um it was
insane but but the crazy thing was that
my first girlfriend was was English and
she was uh she was a she was a model for
like um like teen like nightwear or
something like that and so she came from
London because her mother married an Air
Force guy and so my first girlfriend was
like this English brunette model I was
like this is how's this even possible
like I was just watching Weird Science
and My First Girlfriend is this it was
very very weird and and I was very
insecure about it cuz I was like there's
no way the whole time there's no way
there's no and I was like which is not
the right attitude and when you're
saying that out loud and you're with her
there's no way no way can't touch your
shoulder oh there's no way no way
there's no way no way why you're having
sex there just no way there's just no
way what no way there's no way you're
totally leaving
me can we at least finish this first do
you take this woman no way to be your
lovly
let yeah there's no way baby born
there's no way how how my new book how
my life with the real Kelly Le
[Laughter]
Brock